[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash pretty much
how it's been so let's check out these
website dates let's check out what days
I'm going to what places now a lot of
these places are sold out so I don't
know which one so I'm just going to same
anyway Foxwoods Connecticut November
November 1st Bethlehem Pennsylvania for
some reason November 2nd even though
Jesus isn't going to be there it's
called Bethlehem November even though
Jesus is everywhere Rochester New York I
think that sold out
Royal Oak Michigan saw it these are sold
out mm-hmm
Tampa Florida I think I have maybe a
little tickets left on the third show
Hollywood Florida El Paso Texas in
Houston Texas Puri Illinois December
29th and then Chicago Illinois for New
Year's Eve and anyway
yeah dude so but that's that's those so
those are the dates so go go to Crystal
you calm and get those tickets go to
Chris Lee Adama get got calm get those
tickets the life rips hoodies and the
t-shirts are shipping in three to two
days about two days and so they'll be
sending out so you guys will be [ __ ]
ripping life and wearing a life Rip's
hoodie and life is gonna just keep on
ripping you know what I mean so just
remember life keeps on [ __ ] ripping
and you know I never been so excited for
some some merch because I love that [ __ ]
I love library but no no
so you guys are great man some of you
guys are probably [ __ ] killers even
that you listen to this you probably
[ __ ] killed someone and that's [ __ ]
up don't ever kill anybody and I mean
for the most part don't ever kill
anybody and then some of you guys do
like shitty stuff even though you
listening you're true babies and you
steal stuff and you steal stuff from
people and you [ __ ] rob people and
you probably beat the [ __ ] out of people
and that's not cool but for all of you
guys that don't kill don't beat the [ __ ]
out of people and don't rob stuff and
don't do all this stuff like pillaging
then you know what dude this one's for
you you understand me
but also let's do a [ __ ] body check
dude all right
let's do a [ __ ] body check we haven't
done a body check on this show
[ __ ] lower back in pain always yes
[ __ ] dude did I sleep [ __ ] up last
two nights ago yeah did I wake up and
did it [ __ ] hurt my neck for some
reason didn't feel like I was sleeping
literally on the top of my head and my
body was straight-up [ __ ] upside down
like that yes did I wake up I didn't
hurt so much as it could I not even work
out yes did I still do sprints and try
it yes did it loosen it up my body yes
did it made me feel like I wish I did go
to the gym yes but I didn't so it's all
good and then later on that night did it
hurt more yes
did the pain start to move to the other
side of my neck es why does that happen
I don't know okay this is still hurt
this morning to desert yeah all right is
okay sure it's probably fine it's gonna
be fine in partly three days I'm not
even 40 yet I'm the youngest guy you've
ever [ __ ] met but dude my [ __ ]
lips are chapped - yes oh dude my lips
are chapped [ __ ] yeah dude even though I
was in San Diego and not [ __ ] oh dude
is San Diego Drive [ __ ] maybe I don't
even know but my lips ever yes with the
chapter places that they'd never been
checked before yes do I usually get it
on the [ __ ] upper part of my lip yes
was it on the [ __ ] upper parts but
closer to the sides my lips yes both yes
and dude
it goes get better and then did it get
to the [ __ ] good old telling me I
prefer to the middle lip
yes how does it move pain and chapped
lips move my lips are [ __ ] chapped
Braille my lips are [ __ ] chapped
but let's our [ __ ] chat slips a Jeff
my lips are [ __ ] Jeff brill
worse 80s rap song of all time no way
dude the freaks come out at night
Brill my lips are [ __ ] chapped
see ya killing it dude next hurting back
certain lips are chapped nice and every
time I say a malady guess what happens
people flood my dancehall you know it's
actually good for it is the [ __ ] road
holistic moments are launched I know
what you got to do is all this to come
what say you can go darker but hey we
live it said look I know you're coming
in Minneapolis I got a doctor and some
less okay guess what I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not gonna go to a doctor and I'm not
gonna [ __ ] get him on school you know
throw some [ __ ] dirt on it man on my
lips but yeah anyway my lips are chapped
drank so much water put some [ __ ]
birds bees wax on it didn't help didn't
know all good
so anyway dude I [ __ ] you know so I
got chapped lips cool neck hurts back is
you know that song my neck my back that
shit's about [ __ ] pain I have has
nothing to do with [ __ ] with being a
[ __ ] my neck my back lick my [ __ ] and
my crack is deplorable well that [ __ ]
was in like [ __ ] in 1999 - she started
getting whatever it was so so so nasty
like that but let's [ __ ] do this do
it I'm gonna tell you something right
now
San Diego you know how I feel about you
all right you know how I felt about you
in the past years when I go to San Diego
and I played a la jolla La Jolla Comedy
Store it's always some [ __ ]
holier-than-thou white guys that get
drunk that think that everything's
offensive even though it's filled with
Republicans it's still very weird
San Diego you know when I played the
House of Blues I had to throw out people
before I even got on stage because there
were drunk princesses and bras look did
I have a good time know that I still get
bags okay didn't like it added some
dates on this follow-the-leader tour for
[Music]
for a San Diego put up one sold out very
quickly put up another one sold out very
quickly put up a third one sold out not
as quickly but still even before the
show started all good okay now I was
ready I was ready dude I was ready for
some [ __ ] combat comedy you know what
I'm talking about and I don't like
combat comedy a lot of people think that
I do like combat comedy because I like
to slam pillow but the truth is dude I
don't like to slam people you understand
sure I'll [ __ ] open the door you know
to Denny's for anybody
large or small male/female don't care I
don't even care if you have disabilities
everyone gets equal slams it doesn't
matter you all feel like a person if
you're gonna [ __ ] you know what I
mean step into the Octagon now you're
gonna get a Denny's Grand Slam if you
[ __ ] so I'm ready for some comic
Holly I don't like a lot people think I
do because they do it I take it to the
[ __ ] streets of Twitter I take it to
the streets that you know I'm I laughed
laugh actor YouTube people are
Heckerling heckling and you got the
videos and I'm just [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
people think I like that I've weaned it
out over the time because I have Netflix
specials in a [ __ ] Comedy Central
special and people think that now that
okay he's actually legit comedian it
doesn't do although only a clap acts but
that I'm ready to take it to the streets
at Twitter but I did not want to I'm
like one of those [ __ ] syrup I'm like
one of those serial killers that's just
like I don't want to do it you know but
I have to no not even that like a hit
man I don't want to do that but I need
to feed my family the feeding the family
in this case is me showing people what's
up that's the most
for a thing for me showing people what's
up people say Chris but don't be mean
but I say but look you need to know
right they said but Chris don't take him
to the streets of Twitter but I say but
he needs to know
but he didn't tag you that's right
because I searched my name but isn't
that petty I don't think so I think more
of it is that he needs to know you
understand if this is the Internet and
this is what the Internet is then that
[ __ ] needs to know what this
Internet is so that's it okay somebody
did it just right now it's a parking
somebody tweeted something I just lamps
whatever it doesn't matter dude my point
is I was all ready for some combat
comedy first show went off without a
hitch
second show went off without a hitch
third show went out now I throw a guy
out but it was still not so bad for San
Diego it was fine did I throw out a guy
yes did I do it very quickly yes did I
do it in the part of my act where I the
only place I could do it yes did the
[ __ ] security escort him out yes did
he [ __ ] throw down a trash can in the
lobby when he was escorted out yes
did he try and fight the security yes
did they call the cops yes did the cops
come yes did they put him in handcuffs
yes did his girl try and kick the cops
and then the cops slammed the girl to
the ground yes is that San Diego yes but
still once in the three shows in that
bag so San Diego I've come around dude
dude I've come around man I had a good I
had good three shows now one guy that
was surely stockier than he is tall and
had a backwards [ __ ] Hurley hat
surely and had a flannel buttoned up all
the way to his [ __ ] neck surely and a
girl with a group with a body that does
it isn't that good but isn't pretty
passable for not working out surely was
trying to ruin it but that the cops come
and do a [ __ ] osoto gari and put her
on the ground and cuff him up and put
him in the [ __ ] drunk Tech yes so San
Diego I'm coming around dude still to
those people but also sad
I've come around I'm a morning DJ my
babies I got a [ __ ] keyboard dude and
I use it but that's it dude so I had a
good time so San Diego dude I stayed at
the [ __ ] penury hotel and usually
when I go into [ __ ] a town you know
in my head I'm like don't talk to me
when I check in I don't want people
saying [ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ] ID
you know I don't like to be bothered
with fans I like them when they like me
from afar I don't like them number one
staring if you look at me dance the way
if you see the 50 cent sign
what's the 50 cent line if you see be a
public don't stare be mine whatever the
[ __ ] it is I don't know whatever the
[ __ ] it is I used to think that was
weird but now I get it
because almost famous is 50 cent so so I
see it I don't like to be doing this
[ __ ] but then when they say when was I
saying so what are they saying then they
get yeah so but secretly I'm ready for
it
wasn't happening so much in San Diego I
was I guess because I'm close to LA and
it wasn't because I was close to LA it
was because I wasn't even close to the
most famous person staying at the hotel
because it was the San Diego
International Film Festival now why do
they call it the San Diego International
Film Festival when it's [ __ ] 30
minutes away from LA it doesn't need to
say it's international even though it is
international because you they accept
[ __ ] movies from all over the place I
get it but don't say it - trying to make
you [ __ ] sound better
it doesn't matter is it very sandy aegon
yes but I was in the elevator and I saw
the guy from [ __ ] Chernobyl and I
told my dad I saw the guy for the lead
from Chernobyl and he said Oh which one
from Chernobyl and I said the [ __ ]
goddamn lead and he said well which one
is that and I said did you see it and he
said yes and I said well then the guy
who is in it the most and then he said
oh and they said the guy's name and I
didn't know what his name was and my mom
said yeah and that whole conversation is
interesting because it didn't need to
happen
Denis tan my dad's the king of that [ __ ]
dude yeah I saw the leader
noble and the in an elevator Oh which
one is the lead well you're a [ __ ]
director and a producer in Hollywood so
you surely know what a lead is right
well yeah but which one was it
well did you see the show while I only
saw the first three episodes okay so the
guy that was in those episodes the most
then he said the guys named Jared Harris
and then I said yes
conversation over did we need to have it
no people need to get their [ __ ]
together but I did that too like father
like son the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree and it's not my fault
did his dad Vincent do it probably I
don't know but did [ __ ] my grandpa
everyone called him isn't him I we
called him grandpa BAM everyone called
him BAM because when he was a kid he was
skinny as a bamboo stick but he wasn't
skinny when he was older so it was
always confusing for me as a kid my
grandpa BAM
anyway it's a [ __ ] New York in the
fifth [ __ ] 30s to be an in Vincent
but also go by BAM you know what I mean
like that old [ __ ] like the old
[ __ ] like hey BAM yeah don't call me
that my name is Vincent yeah you're
skinny like a bamboo stick
yeah whatever I don't want to be called
BAM it doesn't matter and it's stuck and
it kept sticking and then just a montage
of him growing up hey get in fights
[ __ ] and [ __ ] hey Dylan and that's
where I was that's where I was
everyone knew me as BAM you know it kind
of grew on me
than just him [ __ ] dealing drugs so
anyway damn my grandpa BAM
so whatever the [ __ ] dude so anyway what
I'm trying to say is San Diego I've come
around but uh it's all good and I was in
Riverside - everyone always talks about
look when you say you're going to
Riverside everyone always talks about
how Riverside they're like oh man you
stay in the night I hope not
dude it [ __ ] ripped I did Riverside I
loved performing in Riverside stayed the
night in Riverside okay I stayed the
night in Riverside man that's an hour
and a half away I stayed the night dude
do you understand me
and I stayed in a hotel that was not
good fine
now did by the way there was some kind
of [ __ ] [ __ ] parade in Riverside
or something and it really pissed me off
I woke up it woke me up in the morning I
heard people go like boom little uluru
and then I was like I'm saying am I
dreaming this and then they just heard
coming closer closer and then I just
kept hearing blue and I was like [ __ ]
Riverside dude it does suck man but then
I woke up and there was just some I
don't know what [ __ ] parade was going
on on Saturday or Friday or what was it
I guess it was Friday morning who the
[ __ ] has a parade on Friday morning
Riverside that was the best they could
get they were like can we get a Saturday
or Sunday parade and they were like nice
Riverside man parade they're moving they
get to San Diego in LA by by [ __ ]
it's Saturday and Sunday all right let's
just do it Friday and then so they did
their parade I don't even know if there
was a parade I just kept [ __ ] waking
up by the time I woke up woke up it was
it was done it wasn't really a pretty
but definite was a parade though it was
like just people
marching around and [ __ ] but then I went
outside and I got some coffee that was
good and I got a breakfast sandwich that
was good there was a Coffee Bean and Tea
Leaf right there there's cute little
town dude I feel like Riverside is on
the come up man but had a good time in
Riverside the crowds are always good in
Riverside I don't know why people are
always like yeah but that's because they
don't have anything to do bro they look
like they're doing just fine also some
places that don't have anything to do
their crowds suck like in North
Battleford when I was in Canada and
every piece of artwork was a [ __ ] tan
and aquamarine Eagle so but ya know so I
did so Riverside show was [ __ ] awesome
and then we went and we got it ah dude
my [ __ ] both of the guys I took to
open for me Craig and Mike were dude
they took all the mercy I packed all the
merch in they didn't even pack it they
put it in I said I'm getting a Sprinter
van for the weekend and they were like
ah cool and they usually pack up like
three suitcases of merch and stuff it
all in there and instead they didn't
they just took the boxes of merch and
put it in the van on the way to
Riverside and we got out of the car and
I was like what the [ __ ] and there were
like eight boxes of merch and I was like
what is all this [ __ ] and they were like
oh we're just gonna leave it in the van
and I was like what and they were like
we're just gonna put it in the van right
and I was like no what are you talking
about and he said we're not with this
van isn't with us for the weekend and I
said [ __ ] no it's not dude now let me
explain why that's stupid now everybody
if you like me your Bloods boiling right
now even just reminiscing about it okay
I want you to just take a sentiment all
right
would you just relax I want you to
[ __ ] take that blood I want you dial
it down a notch I want you to [ __ ] I
want you to turn down the heat I want it
to go from [ __ ] medium to [ __ ]
light medium I wanted to just I want you
to take the oven and I want you to just
turn it down okay now why does that make
us mad
now I'll tell you why it makes us mad
okay here's why getting a get in a car
to take it from from LA to Riverside
it's about 300 bucks okay get in your
car to to take it from Riverside to to
San Diego spent 300 bucks okay get in
your car from San Diego back to LA about
500 bucks okay so you know what that's
all expensive fine
it doesn't matter sure I you know I need
to get their [ __ ] bags bags Dan but
need to bring it back okay
that's about a [ __ ] thousand dollars
whatever you want to call the bit more
than a thousand dollars less all good
okay if I rent the goddamn driver all
weekend yeah sure no dents but that's
going to be five grand
okay now that's well it's actually could
be more than five grand it's gonna be
[ __ ] 7 8 9 grand now would I do that
sure no dents but would I do that no
because it just makes no goddamn sense
to anyone who's not a caveman all right
or a four-year-old okay so there we go
now that's where the Bloods [ __ ]
risin okay now of course I told you to
the [ __ ] thought now I understand if
you're well if you're like me even
listen to me and if you're a longtime
fans job then I understand your Bloods
boiling because you like me you get it
we're part of the cult arc when you're a
cult your blood boils together so our
blood is boiling it's boiling it's it's
piping [ __ ] hot dude and I'm mad now
but let me tell you why why it's real
hard to keep the blood from [ __ ]
really bursting out of my [ __ ] eye
boss okay Mike's been opening me with me
for six years we have done hundreds and
hundreds of cities and we haven't never
one time ever done it that way okay so
those of you still with us those of you
who didn't pass on yet because of the
blood coming out of your eyes and ears
okay because I'm Zen right now I'm just
chillin he says well [ __ ] now we got to
take all the boxes with us to the hotel
and then back to San Diego and then back
to the thing and then we got to put it
in the box and the Vic and I say you
know when you get so mad that you're
just kind of like yeah there's nothing
he can do and okay cool so we'll just
chill and I'll be mad right
I say that's cool man I'm not carrying a
[ __ ] box so now he has to deal with
it because he [ __ ] this is my
impression of him and then [ __ ] Craig
to was like oh that's when I thought I
thought that we were taking that oh yeah
you got [ __ ] mmm 19 grand to just
[ __ ] do it quick farts broke yeah you
[ __ ] new dude do some mental do some
thought man do thought hey man do
thought thought do it not do that beyond
the first Sun take it there how could
you be such a [ __ ] ignoramus now if
Mike were here he would say ignoramus oh
I never heard that word take it past
that guy's getting all pissed caring
[ __ ] boxes and I'm sitting around
like I'm a [ __ ] like I'm a laughing
King hmm like I'm that guy oh look at
them carry the boxes it's their own
fault there's nothing they can do
dude if I play a character in a real
[ __ ] serious drama and I'm like that
you think I won't win an Oscar dude [ __ ]
you you think I won't win an Oscar I
want a [ __ ] Oscar and everybody on
set when I'm doing
like I don't know if that's the move and
then it comes out bro that's it wraps my
neck hurts
Melissa jabs my lower back hurts it's
all good anyway dude shipstation
when you're selling online getting your
orders out can be a real pain like my
back or neck or chapped lips choosing
who to ship with is time-consuming it's
expensive so many carriers to choose
from how do you know you're making the
best choice I use a ship station for all
my merch people tweet me how fast they
got their merch it takes like two days
sometimes sometimes it runs next day
that's because a ship station thank you
if you're selling something you need
this I'm making the choice for you
therefore you don't need to use your
brain about this just use it my babies
you're selling on your website or on
Amazon Etsy eBay ship station it all
makes your life so much easier just use
ship station I've saved so much time and
money by using ship station and now you
will too they offer discounts on
shipping costs for the same the same
postage discounts usually reserved for
the fortune 500 companies that's all you
now do it right now my listeners get to
try ship station free for 60 days and
when you use offer code Congrats see for
yourself why ship station is rated
number 1 by online sellers just visit
ship station calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in congrats
that's ship station calm then enter
offer code congrats ship station calm
make ship happen zapier growing a
business is hard especially when you're
wasting hours every day moving data from
emails to spreadsheets to your crm to
wherever really shouldn't that kind of
stuff just happen without you lifting a
finger
zabi er can help now of course I don't
lift the finger because why should i
when I have one fire but I know for a
fact that he uses it for automating his
workflow and keeping track of all my
money zapier is the easiest way to
automate your work it connects all your
business off
and handles work for you so you can
focus on the things that matter most zap
your let's zap your lets you instantly
engage with leads send them to a CRM or
spreadsheet then notify your team so
they can act fast on every opportunity
join more than 4.5 million people who
are saving an average of 40 hours per
month using zapier that's awesome right
now through November try zap your free
by going to our special link zapier
dot-com slash Congrats that's za p IE
are.com / congrats for your free 14-day
trial zapier dot slash Congrats comm
shepherd.com / congrats wan fire ruined
it zap yer calm / Congrats typo 1 fire
is all of course 1 fire anyway yeah so
let me see your arm bro what's this no
oh all right so bad friends so um so
anyway uh it's about friend oh no what
my friends get to do so um so anyway
mmmm-hmmm then one of the vans we took
back from San Diego bro now look I don't
know if I got an iron deficiency or what
let me be real with you babies when I go
to a hotel room I keep that [ __ ] 7675
might as well be an icebox for me I'll
keep that [ __ ] 76 I go in and the
[ __ ] air is always blaring first
thing daddy does is turn that [ __ ] off I
let that I let the [ __ ] mechanism
rest for about five minutes and then
that he turns that [ __ ] heat up bro
76 at least you understand me
okay now my opener Mike is a fat [ __ ]
alright now we know about fat fox dude
they get what say it together if you're
in your car you're in your cubicle
everyone said together they get what
sweaty okay their hands are all clammy
and they're [ __ ] you know what I mean
it's all [ __ ] sweat he's got all
sweaty sweat they sweat on there where
everyone say it together
forehead everyone stay together [ __ ]
sweat where everyone said together under
their under their nose in their lip you
ever see that [ __ ] butt when you were
remember that one kid when you were in a
like fourth grade that got this sweat
above his lip what the [ __ ] was wrong
with that kid bro I could sweat I could
be in the Sahara Desert with a [ __ ]
parka on and snow pants and straight up
a ski hat and if and I would never get
the beads of sweat above my lip dude
that kids was always so [ __ ] that kid
I would stare at that kid man when he
would talk and be like why are there
beads of sweat above his lip with the
[ __ ] sweats on their lip bro
grow up hurry up grow up and grow a
mustache hide it dude I'd rather see
someone with a wet stache than a [ __ ]
beat it up her lip ill dude ill bro
anyway he's like oh it's so hot so we
turn on the air fine you know you know
like with cars I've literally if you can
get your temperature perfect in your car
i straight-up don't believe you
it's either too cold or too hot that's
how cars go because you're in too close
proximity to the [ __ ] air
conditioners of the heater all right it
cramped up you're basically in a [ __ ]
little thing you know you're looking
this movable large embryo anyway so
so I went so it was cold and then so it
was cold and then and I was like it's
too hot I was too cold so I put the [ __ ]
on and dude when I turn the air off the
thing still counts what degrees it is so
I turn the air off and it quickly ripped
up to 82 degrees now guess what I am
happy and I'm serious and I'm not
sweating I'm chilling you'll have an
iron deficiency
Maebh I fall asleep for a little bit now
sometimes Mike will [ __ ] sneak the
air on but that's when I get rip roarin
Matt okay
so he didn't do it this time I wake up
bro he's naked
he took off all his clothes except for
his [ __ ] Spanx underwear and I look
over and I'm like this [ __ ]
really has underwear on and that made me
happy because that's how you do it you
don't [ __ ] around dude you don't change
the air conditioning for the guy who's
paying for the [ __ ] van by the way
Craig was on my side he was like I like
getting high anyway you can't [ __ ]
get your air right in the car what was
the deal with that
everyone's log said about Tesla [ __ ]
Prius and all that [ __ ] bro get the air
right man that's what I'll be happy
so I'm trying to [ __ ] and I'm cool
with my sexuality man they could do some
events I don't give a [ __ ] man
Diggs flopping around don't care forgot
him I was back for a little bit
Oh bro I wanted to talk about this this
made me laugh so uh oh also wait hold on
we were in San Diego oh man this made me
laugh we were in San Diego mm-hmm and we
went to go get a lunch me and the three
it mean the two of us Craig and Mike we
sit down we're at a bar it's got like a
bit of a bar menu find whatever okay I
get the turkey wrap it's got a wheat
wrap and your boys trying to keep it
healthy okay it's fine Mike goes like
this I'll get the the Frank sandwich and
I say oh cool
in my head and he says and she says okay
right sit down on her pad and then she
and then Mike says is that a
cheeseburger and she says yeah now we
all know it's not we all know it's
hotdogs because nobody would ever
describe a food as a Frank when it's not
a goddamn hot dog right if I was eating
a cheeseburger and I said hey man this
ballpark be Frank sure is good you'd say
quick get that guy to the hospital
cuz he doesn't know what words are all
right
so by the way what the waitress did was
correct he said that's a cheeseburger
right and she said yeah because you
wouldn't want to make a guy who's
obviously lost his mind or broken his
brain upset you just agree with crazy
people it's like when a [ __ ] guy on
meth is on the sidewalk and says you
know Jesus is coming right you just say
yeah yeah yeah so he said I'll have the
Franks and she said great and he said
that's a cheeseburger right and in her
head this was a crazy guy on meth with
his pants around his ankles saying you
know Jesus is coming right and that's
what I thought too I thought oh how sad
Mike's brain broke keep it at bay she
said yes I wanted to shake her hand but
I didn't make a big deal now cut to
obviously way too long later because
it's a bar and bar food always takes too
long she puts down two big messy hotdogs
and I look at Mike's face and it's not
good not because he's [ __ ] a six but
because his face did something like what
the [ __ ] she leaves and he says I don't
want this and I said huh and he says I
thought it was a cheeseburger and I said
huh and he said did you see me ask if it
was a cheeseburger and I said yeah and
then she said yes it was a cheeseburger
and I said course and he said but it's
hotdogs
and I said yeah gosh and he said why did
you say it was a cheeseburger and I said
cuz she prays broken your Franks you
ordered some ballpark beef franks you
asked if it was a cheeseburger she said
yes
because she didn't want to deal with you
taking your dick out or something
[ __ ] all over the table because
you're obviously crazy purse hey dude
I'll get the ball perfect but uh hey
dude I'll get the ball part be Franks
okay
is that a salad yes great here you go oh
what the [ __ ]
this isn't a salad no you [ __ ]
[ __ ] it says Franks you're 36
he ate it he ate the whole [ __ ] thing
you know why fat slob that's why that's
also why it's [ __ ] too hot in the
goddamn Sprinter van you know it's all
your fault man nothing on this nothing
on this podcast is my fault it's never
been my fault I've never ever I've never
had my fault anyway goat the faves
Yeezys Jordans off lights if you're
gonna buy sneakers for a few hundred
dollars how can you be sure they're the
real thing
look you can't really unless you use
goat because goat calm is the safest way
to buy and sell authentic sneakers
online dude you don't want to be
thinking you getting antic sneakers and
walk it around and then a sneaker heads
like yellows are fake and then you're
embarrassed and you piss your pants goat
is the largest marketplace in the world
for authentic Easy's Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy every detail is inspected
from the stitching and color to the size
and weight Goat certifies every pair of
sneakers on their site matches exact
factory specifications with over half a
million sneakers on the platform and 10
users you won't find a better prices for
verified 100% authentic sneakers and
anywhere else find the perfect 100%
authentic sneaker at Goat calm /
Congrats that's Goat calm / Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
and that's a good thing because your
babies and you know but you've got to go
right now before the sneakers you want
are gone they go fast man especially the
good ones when you go to go calm /
Congrats spell go8 e.com / Congrats
intersect announcing intersect festival
by AWS where music art and technology
converge don't you like when things
converge doesn't that make it better
alright there say no more taking place
December 6th and 7th at the Las Vegas
festival grounds right on the Vegas
strip so it'll be fun
intersect is presented by Amazon Web
Services born out of the massive after
party for their reinvent conference now
open to the public for the first time
ever featuring Foo Fighters Anderson Pak
Kacey Musgraves Beck Flying Lotus Leon
bridges her spoon Jamie xx Thundercat
churches Brandi Carlile and many more
hey have you ever heard of those guys uh
yeah
Rolling Stone says the festival has
booked headliners to rival that of
Coachella and lined up enough tech
projects to bill itself as a mini South
by Southwest oh that's that's awesome
alright go for a limited time
congratulations listeners can save $10
on two-day general admission tickets to
intersect by going to intersect fest
calm and Entering offer code congrats to
unlock the deal
that's intersect fest calm and promo
code congrats to save yourself some cash
and be a part of this incredible
experience to be a part dare I say of
history uh uh congratulations is brought
to you by Cash Shop the official our app
of the log cabin it's all good
chillings we're all chillings dude
there's a thing you can put on your
penis if your penis is small and it's
called a penis extender and and you can
have sex with your girl with it
like you can buy it put it on your [ __ ]
and make your [ __ ] larger I guess and
then have sex with your girl with it hey
don't do that okay do you know why first
of all it's emasculating use your
regular [ __ ] and if it's small own it or
go down and munch some box okay or go
down and kiss that fried butterfly u
nderstand
hope my mom's not listening to this one
but don't get a penis extender just
[ __ ] die and hopefully next time you
come back its bigger love honey penis
extenders you know love honey how did
they make it grosser honey
dude extra one inch silicone penis
extender love honey mega-mighty three
extra inches hey nothing's mega and
mighty about three inches you know if
you had a little [ __ ] ass dude that was
three inches right now and just like
well hello mother Miley you just step on
him by crunch oh look at this basics
this clear textured penis extender okay
it's got [ __ ] speed bumps all over it
yeah but that feels [ __ ] awesome but
that goes bonkers dude what are they
always like you know ill you know it
hooks on your balls you put it over your
dick and it hooks on your balls so it
doesn't go anywhere so when you thrust
you don't leave it in there hey unsafe
yeah it doesn't feel good all of your
[ __ ]
in there okay hey dude don't do that and
let me tell you why man cuz nothing
sexier than a dude doing it for him I
know girls would be like but I gotta get
off but you don't really think that you
want to be you want to be taken like a
[ __ ] caveman and alike you know enemy
tangling a [ __ ] caveman unless you're
in like a relationship or some [ __ ] but
like the first few times you have sex
with a girl they don't they want you to
just [ __ ] do it that's what they want
man you ever been with a girl and she's
just like a cake but finish and you're
like oh it's not fun you're like okay
finish you're like ah for real okay the
way it is look doc Johnson big warhead
eight inch penis sleeve don't call it
warhead look the way she's holding it so
nice like holding it like so nice like
this
hey warhead penis so anyway uh I was
gonna say oh yeah this is the thing I
really wanted to do though this is the
thing I really wanted to play this [ __ ]
killed me bro this like alright when you
have a job and you're not into it that's
common you know but you think of someone
in a cubicle or you think of someone you
know like a UPS guy just going through
the motions if you're a [ __ ] pastor I
know what this guy is about the blood of
the Lamb dude this guy is a preacher a
preacher is what it is now a lot of you
probably seen this I guess I don't know
but dude this guy is sitting the first
was sitting down do it if you're a
preacher stand the [ __ ] up dude
also don't dress like Garth Brooks this
guy's dressed like so this guy literally
looks like he's about to sing - in front
of 440,000 people a country music yeah I
pray I pray
I pray I pray usually he'll be healing
if he keeps taking [ __ ] over I pray
deliverance deliverance deliverance
deliverance deliverance
first of all guy get new words you know
you don't need to say it deliverance
deliverance deliverance deliverance
deliverance alright so he checks his
phone number one right now here we go
checks his phone or yes Lord yes Lord
yes Lord yes Lord I mean dude delivered
stole a box yes Lord yes Lord yes Lord
yes Lord yes Lord thinking is pretty
sure that most arid and Arabic Arabic
Mandarin EASA ratatata la mouche kiya
yes on your way have your way have your
way have your way
checking his phone he's checking his
phone if you're listening to this and
not watching it he's checking his phone
and then so by the way these are the
things on the table his phone his
glasses a bottle of water and olive oil
okay
his wife's anxiously
Oh
go back to yes Lord yes Lord
[Music]
realized he was like wait I got a system
works
no that was what his wife said she's
leaving she's my wife says she's leaving
and when he said hallelujah she said
she's leaving the flatscreen
oh you see the restaurant where the way
I mean at this point I guess a waiter or
something picks up the olive oil and
wipes the table down and what the [ __ ]
is going on
Fellini movie
[Music]
hallelujah thank you lord thank you Lord
God touch this touch this right now
touch this situation so perfect touch
this situation but the power of God
touch this situation by the power of the
Holy Ghost by the anointing by the
anointing by the anointing by the
anointing Miramon da da ba da dun da da
ba baby Shalu Kay do that though not
juvenile no Master P dude I could do
that man the way you're doing for what
the [ __ ] dude that's so dumb
hey man first of all be in a better
place
number two don't dress like that number
three
clear the table number four don't check
your phone number other buy lamp [ __ ]
stand up
and number six don't do this sort of
breath
rumba - Ambra bum ba-bum ba-bum Lord yes
Lord yes Lord yes yes yes yes Lord yes
yes deliver us from deliver us from evil
Rome butter rum butter rum rum rum rum
that a lump a damn Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
rim / mMmmm champion Bam Bam Bam limp
Biskit rim better be a member of mmm mmm
buddy buddy LLL Hawaii a pop pop
whatever we put up rum bum bum bum bum
the Little Italy oh oh really oh oh Chim
Chim Chim Chim Chim Chim ER Samia from
from from from from from voom voom
um remember macheted in my car
remember remember Rome [ __ ] in my car
from from Rome master P dude at Master P
dude what the [ __ ] is he doing what
straight up the preacher the preacher
dude remember my mom um such a [ __ ]
dude get a real job
the Lord had nothing to do with that you
know the Lord was literally texting him
stop that's why I checked his phone
Wow that [ __ ] made me laugh when I first
saw that I love Erard
and that's it
let's see what the comments say dude
that's the moment some favorite shits I
know there's like four people clapping
which is the best Wow somebody said he
went from speaking tongues to orgasms
Kay oh wow somebody said he just stops
talking and starts telling Master P okay
cool great I'm a hack cool
I had no idea if we were saying what I
was thinking cool yeah oh and the other
one is just a pitcher and does the
person have to pick the time that the
spirit is moving to clean the table my
son just has to be was playing Pokemon
go I don't get that part but mm-hmm wow
dude just unbelievable dude preachers
are hilarious let's look up some other
ones preachers preacher what do I do
preaching okay
these guys are such [ __ ] even the
good ones mm-hmm look look at these
titles stop blocking your miracle okay
Wow who is this guy Tony Evans one farce
tell me to look up Benny Hinn oh is that
the guy with the coat like oh yeah this
guy's great oh this guy's great dude
this is great Benny Hinn historic
Crusades Atlanta 2010 this guy keeps on
whipping people with his jacket and they
think they're getting Savior first of
all I look at this [ __ ] he looks like
he will be on the show see quest and
there's nothing oh yeah
Wow dude he's tossing his blazer at
people oh wow these people are getting
ruptured disks falling on the ground
no [ __ ] if this guy did this to me I
would stand there look at look at look
at again the Lord has nothing to do with
Blazers okay
[ __ ]
joso has a control Oh such a control
freak watch watch
oh so the hands are said quick take that
audience Kunti said Kunti in it hey men
said Kunti oh wow this is a salt
straight up you just smashed the girl in
her face the guys singing you know
[Music]
there's some oh dude David Brent how he
dance
yes though I mean the way the guy in the
back just going oh well the guy's just
thank that show me a [ __ ] heads [ __ ]
take that nothing's happening you know
don't do all this just chill play Sudoku
wow this guy keeps doing this did this
guy did this to me I'd [ __ ] lay him
out
Wow everyone he's doing it to looks like
Jeff Foxworthy it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable dude they all have the Jeff
Foxworthy starter kit or whatever the
[ __ ] the guy in the back is the bass
dude how he knows his [ __ ] he just
keeps killing it with the song
[Applause]
[Music]
we just said what happened
[Applause]
she had rheumatoid arthritis right here
we go heal them tonight and here he goes
just push their faces in then they fell
to the ground it's so rude and they
still have rheumatoid arthritis that's
him just up and it gonna push their face
again to the ground and these [ __ ]
idiots are just buying it
these idiots everyone here is a [ __ ]
is a freakin idiot unbelievable dude
let's just hear him talk a little bit
because guarantee you this guy had a
three-episode arc on see question 19 I
begin by sharing a story that III want
to talk to you about I was many years
ago okay
I was many years reaching for my friend
Melanie kina we all love Melanie ki she
she she's like one of my sweetest
friends in the whole world
well I went to Denver Colorado this was
8485 I walked down the aisle I look at a
lady I said lady bombing the Lord tells
me you have cancer and she says no I
don't I said yes you do
she said no I don't okay I said yes you
do Justin we got into an and an argument
now Melanie is killing on the platform
getting all upset with me killing I said
lady the Lord told me you have cancer
she said no i don't i said yes you do
she said no i don't i said yes we get
that and i said listen i said if i am
wrong on god talking to me about you
I'll quit the ministry I was dead bald I
said don't you tell me you don't when
the Lord tells me you do okay you're
crazy
I am NOT leaving till you admit you have
it oh wow imagine the Lord speaks to us
a [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy is in a
relationship
we know he spoke
look look at all the black people in our
life that's right yeah and the white
people are like okay well we'll see
and I said to the lady I said now lady I
said all God has not spoken to me or
you're lying
well you can imagine the tension in the
auditorium buy that for your crazy Bill
melanic he was sitting on the platform
the mighty low one yes well she and I
talked about this but it was the lady
had just heard a preacher who preached
on faith and who said to the
congregation don't confess it and now
the lady starts to weep to disavow
though and the whole church heard say to
me I am not supposed to say it I am not
supposed to say it and then I got really
angry that's not very good faith does
not deny fact yet nobody ever came to
Jesus and said I'm not supposed to say
it I saw the person I was comparing
himself to Jesus goddamn is [ __ ]
[ __ ] what is [ __ ] just robbing
people you know robbing poor people of
money because they want to believe in
something well that's not far from what
we're doing you can get your life rips
hoodies at Crystal a calm anyway I guess
that's it huh we just crossed the our
threshold and we had fun my babies and
now I get to do whatever the [ __ ] I want
at another day you guys are [ __ ] cool
man
download download the cash out for free
on the App Store or Google Play market
oh and I forgot about this you can text
me I'm trying to respond to as many as I
can
eight one eight two three nine seventy
eighty seven
you can do that and I'm trying to
respond as many as I can
I got literally 60,000 you're texting me
right now uh-huh and you get the life
rips hoodies man those are awesome
they're flying off the shelves you know
what I mean
subscribe to the YouTube channel rate
and review it on iTunes it really helps
us got Foxwoods come in tape it tape it
my special in Minneapolis Tampa Florida
Hollywood Florida
El Paso Houston coming up you know
Chicago Illinois I got another show here
doing Jori Illinois all right you guys
thank you so much appreciate you
listening and keep a real
[Music]